another major story we are following
tonight almost immediately after
president announced that he was
nominating Gina Haspel to be the first
woman to run the CIA well some people on
the left in the media were just waiting
to attack and where did you hear the
reason why take a look at this there is
controversy in her past she was involved
with the torture programs after
September 11th and then involved with
destroying videotapes of the matter also
that might be something that could be
problematic
Gina Hospital has a real history with
enhanced interrogation in the CIA
there's a lot of people raising
questions including John McCain today
about the fact that in 2002 she ran a
so-called black site CIA prison in
Thailand were two terrorism suspects
were tortured
and she also reportedly her name was on
a cable ordering the destruction of
tapes but you support her I do
she clearly presided over a massive
illegal operation that violated both the
US law and international law I'm sure
those orders came down from above her
but that is no excuse typical left-wing
attacks about hospital now Jose
Rodriguez remember him he is the former
head of the CIA national clandestine
service he praised the intelligence that
was gained from these black sites like
the ones that Haspel ran here's what
Rodriguez told me in 2014 this is
crucial those of us who read the
intelligence coming out of our black
sites every morning and who acted on
that intelligence know the value and
basically it led to the destruction of
the organization led to the destruction
of the organization without
interrogation techniques there is no
getting Osama bin Laden she saved
American lives I wish the world was an
evil sadly the world's evil here with
reaction
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka Fox News chief national
correspondent ed Henry by the way Edie
well this is like a full-time gig for
you place it shannon bream what's up
with that was on vacation this week in
short jennifer this teases all right
let's start with the
with you this is a woman as I see it now
they're going to oppose the first woman
ever nominate it to be the CIA director
and they're saying she's too tough on
terror it's just too tough on terrorists
that saved American lives
Jose Rodriguez witnessed the
waterboarding and he knows the
information extracted Shawn this is
almost tailor-made for the Trump White
House if they were to design a strategy
would be they could sit around the table
and say if only the Democrats would
accuse our CIA nominee of being too
tough on terrorists that were just too
tough on trying to take out al Qaeda and
Isis that would be exactly what what
they would like to design and that's
what the Democrats are doing and on top
of that as you say she'd be the first
woman to lead the CIA that is a
wonderful achievement if she's confirmed
and yet you have Democrats like Chuck
Schumer Dianne Feinstein suggesting she
may not get the job here's the bottom
line
the clips you played there are
legitimate questions to be raised about
those techniques there was a great
debate as you remember better than
anyone at the end of the Bush
administration at the beginning of the
Obama administration about all this but
the problem is in almost every one of
those clips the Democratic senators and
various journalists are talking about
the allegations that may have broken law
but not a one of them talked about the
actual intelligence the actionable
intelligence gotten from that to wipe
out terrorists that's the other side and
Jose Rodriguez was couldn't be more
clear to me dr. Gorka if they didn't use
these techniques against KSM that led to
the courier that led to bin Laden that
led to us killing bin Laden now I I wish
the world wasn't full of evil radical
Islamic terrorists that think they're
doing God's will by killing innocent
people but they killed 3,000 Americans
dr. Gorka she to me is a hero you know
look that's why I wrote the book
defeating jihad because we are at war
with evil look the left just wants to
attack a female appointee of a
Republican president they couldn't care
less about whether we tortured people or
not these are all politicians who were
briefed you told the world they were
briefed behind closed doors they had no
issue with the black sites with the
enhanced interrogation techniques but
now they do let's
back in time Shawn the last
administration run by a guy called Obama
who had a female national security
adviser they weren't just involved in
you know things that were dubious when
it comes to enhanced interrogation this
wasn't it this was an administration
that had for the president something
called the threat disposition matrix and
the big iPad on which he would decide
which terrorists were going to kill
today including more than one American
citizen abroad so they want to get high
and mighty about black sites when
they're president and then female
National Security Advisor was killing
Americans without due process dr. korkor
think of the mindset Bill Clinton three
billion dollars energy to North Korea
and this is a good deal for the American
people they're not gonna get nukes
they got news I can't even fathom what
Obama was thinking a hundred and fifty
billion dollars in the hands of Iranian
mullahs chanting death to America and
then the same mindset no we can't dunk
people that we know we're terrorists
that have information about killing
Americans their head in a tank and make
them feel like they're drowning we
better build them soccer fields and make
sure we cater to their dietary needs I
don't understand the mindset help me out
maybe it was missing something let's
look at the reality a transit cop in DC
was charged and prosecuted and put in
federal prison because he thought he was
wiring five hundred dollars to Isis it
was actually an FBI contact as covert
asset five hundred dollars and he goes
to jail for material support to
terrorism mm-hmm the Trump the the Obama
administration gives a hundred and fifty
billion dollars to ours it's I can't
even comprehend how stupid that is
ed Henry other news in Washington
tonight yeah well the other big story of
course is the house passing this bill to
deal with school safety about fifty
billion dollars what it's about is in
training teachers training school
officials to deal with these threats
more money for mental health it's
interesting I think the bottom line you
have Democrats tonight complaining there
are no gun control measures in there but
let's remember
it started out in the immediate
aftermath were it's one month today
since the parkland Florida shooting and
that terrible tragedy it started out in
the immediate hours this is all about
the NRA it's all about gun control as we
got more facts about how the police
didn't respond you know quick enough
some of them were afraid to go in all of
those questions about the FBI not
following up on tips it shifted from gun
control to school safety and so the
houses pass we still need to see the
Senate passing what a display today to
watch all these politicians with their
armed guards showing solidarity for
students wanting to get rid of weapons
all right thank you both great report